welcome back everyone this is part three
in our series on methods and metrics
we're going to talk about generation
metrics you know in the previous
screencast we talked about classifier
metrics those seem conceptually
straightforward at first but turn out to
Harbor lots of intricacies that goes
double at least for Generation
generation is incredibly conceptually
challenging I would say the fundamental
issue here is that there is more than
one effective way to say most things and
so that immediately raises the question
of what we are even trying to measure is
it fluency is it truthfulness
communicative Effectiveness maybe
something else these are all
interestingly different questions after
all you could have a system that was
highly fluent but spewing falsehoods or
even a system that was highly disfluent
but achieving its goals in communication
and those kind of examples show that you
really need to have Clarity on the high
level goals before you can even think
about which metrics to choose for
generation
let's begin the discussion with
perplexity that's a natural starting
point it's a kind of analog of accuracy
but in the generation space
so for some sequence X and some
probability distribution or model that
can assign probability distributions the
perplexity for that sequence according
to that model is really just the
geometric mean of the probabilities
assigned to the individual time steps
and then when we average over an entire
Corpus for the mean perplexity we just
do the geometric mean of the individual
perplexity scores per sequence
properties of perplexity well its bounds
are 1 and Infinity with one the best so
we are seeking to minimize this quantity
it is equivalent to the exponentiation
of the Cross entropy loss this is really
important most modern day language
models use across entropy loss and what
that means is that whether you wanted to
or not you are effectively optimizing
that model for perplexity
what's the value encoded it's something
like does the model assign high
probability to the input sequence
so when we think about assessment what
that means is that we have some
assessment set of sequences we run our
model on those examples we get the
average perplexity across the examples
and we will report that number as an
estimate of system quality
relatedly there are a number of
weaknesses that we really need to think
about first perplexity is heavily
dependent on the underlying vocabulary
one easy way to see this is just to
imagine that we take every token in
these sequences and map them to a single
Unk character in that case we will have
perfect perplexity but we will have a
terrible generation system
perplexity also really does not allow
comparisons between data sets
the issue here is that we don't have any
ground truth on what's a good or bad
perplexity separate from the data and
what that means is that comparing across
two data sets with perplexity numbers is
just comparing incomparables
relatedly even comparisons between
models is tricky you can see this
emerging here because we really need a
lot of things to be held constant to do
a model comparison certainly the
tokenization needs to be the same
certainly the data sets need to be the
same ideally many other aspects of the
systems are held constant when we do a
perplexity comparison otherwise again we
are in danger of comparing incomparables
word error rate might be better and this
is more tightly aligned with actually
human created reference text which could
be a step up from perplexity in terms of
how we think about assessment
this is really a family of measures you
need to pick a distance measure between
strings and then your word error rate is
parameterized by that distance metric
here's the full calculation for a gold
text X
and a predicted text spread we do the
distance between X and prod according to
whatever distance measure we chose and
we divide that by the length of the
reference or gold text
and then when we average over a whole
Corpus what we do is for the numerator
sum up all of the distances between gold
and predicted text and we divide that by
the total length of all of the reference
texts
properties of word error rate its bounds
are zero and infinity with zero the best
it's an error rate so we're trying to
minimize it
the value encoded is something like how
a line is the predicted sequence with
the actual sequence so in that way it's
similar to F scores once you have
thought about your distance metric
weaknesses well it can accommodate just
one reference text our fundamental
challenge here is that there's more than
one good way to say most things whereas
here we can accommodate only a single
way presumably a good one of saying the
thing that we care about
it's also a very syntactic notion by
default most distance metrics are string
edit metrics and they're very sensitive
to the actual structure of the string
and so as a result by and large these
metrics will treat it was good it was
not good and it was great as all
similarly distant from each other when
of course semantically it was good and
it was great are kind of alike and
different from it was not good
blue scores build on intuitions around
word error rate and they're trying to be
more sensitive to the fact that there's
more than one way to say most things
here's how Blues scores work it's again
going to be a balance of precision and
recall but now tailored to the
generation space the notion of precision
is modified engram Precision let's walk
through this simple example here we have
a candidate which is kind of unusual
it's just seven occurrences of the word
the so obviously not a good candidate we
have two reference texts these are
presumed to be human created texts the
modified engram Precision for the is two
over seven there are seven occurrences
of the in the candidate and the two
comes from the reference text that
contains the maximum number of those
that's reference text one it has two
tokens of the whereas reference text two
has just one token of the so we get two
points for that and then the modified
engram Precision for the is two over
seven
that's a notion of precision we need to
balance that with a notion of recall
otherwise we might end up with systems
that do very short Generations in order
to be very precise
and so for recall blue introduces what
they call a brevity penalty and in
essence what this is doing is saying if
the generated text is shorter than the
text I expect from my Corpus I pay a
little penalty once I get to the
expected length you stop paying a recall
or brevity penalty and you start to rely
on the modified engram precision
and the blue score itself is just a
product of the brevity penalty score and
the sum of the weighted modified engram
Precision values for each end what I
mean by that is we could do this for
unigrams bigrams trigrams we could
assign different weight to those
different Notions of engram and all of
those are Incorporated if we want Into
the Blue score
properties of the blue score its bounds
are zero and one with one the best that
we have no expectation for naturalistic
data that any system will achieve one
because there's no way we could have all
the relevant reference texts
conceptually
the value encoded is something like an
appropriate we hope balance of precision
and recall as implemented in that
brevity penalty
it's similar to the word error rate but
it seeks to accommodate the fact that
there are typically multiple suitable
outputs for a given input are kind of
fundamental challenge for generation
weaknesses well there's a long
literature on this
some of it arguing that blue fails to
correlate with human scoring for
translation which is an important
application domain for blue so that's
worrisome
it's very sensitive to the engram order
of things so in that way it is kind of
very attuned to syntactic elements of
these comparisons
it's insensitive to engram type again
that's a notion of string dependence so
that dog the dog and that toaster might
be treated identically with your blue
scoring even though that dog and the dog
are obviously closer to each other than
that toaster
and finally for you have to be really
thoughtful about the domain that you're
operating in because blue might be just
mismatched to the goals of generation in
that space for example Leo at all 2016
in the process of developing and
evaluating neural conversational agents
just argue against Blue as a metric for
dialogue
so think carefully about what your
generations mean what kind of reference
text you actually have and whether or
not everything is aligned given your
high level goals again a common refrain
for this unit of the course
I mentioned two reference-based metrics
and I call them reference-based word
error rate and blue are both like this
because they defend on depend on these
reference texts these human created
texts
others in that family include Rouge and
meteor and what you can see happening
here especially with meteor is that
we're trying to be oriented toward a
task maybe a semantic task like
summarization and also less sensitive to
fine-grained details of the reference
text and the generated text to key into
more semantic Notions meteor does that
with things like stemming and synonyms
and with scoring procedures like cider
and Bert score we actually move into
Vector space models that we might hope
capture many deep aspects of semantics
cider does this this with TF IDF vectors
it's a powerful idea though it does make
it heavily dependent on the nature of
the data set and then Bert score uses
weighted Maxim at the token level to
Define scores between two texts that's a
very semantic notion in fact the scoring
procedure looks a lot like the one that
we use for the Colbert retrieval model
what you can see happening especially
with Bert score is that we're trying to
get away from all the details of these
strings and really key into deeper
aspects of meaning
I thought I'd mention image-based nlg
metrics some of you might be developing
systems that take images as input
produce text and then we want to ask the
question of whether or not that's a good
text for the image
for this task reference-based metrics
like blue and word error rate will be
fine assuming that the human annotations
exist and are kind of aligned with the
actual goal that you have for the text
that you're generating conditional on
these images
but that could be a large burden for
many domains and many tasks we won't
have annotations in the right way for
these reference based metrics so you
might think about reference list metrics
metrics in this space seek to score text
image pairs with no need for human
created references at this moment the
most popular of these is certainly clip
score but there are others like umic and
spurts and the vision here is to drop
the need for human annotation which is a
major bottlene bottleneck for evaluation
and instead just score these image text
pairs in isolation
I think this is really promising we do
have a paper of Christ at all 2022 where
we criticize these referenceless metrics
on the grounds that they are insensitive
to the purpose of the text and the
context in which the image appeared
those are crucial aspects when you think
about our goals for Generation in this
context and it's a shame that these
referenceless metrics are just missing
that information however we are
optimistic that we can design variants
of clip score and related metrics that
can actually bring in these Notions of
quality so I think references metrics
may be a fruitful path forward for
evaluation for image based nlg
and then finally to round this out I
thought I'd offer a more high level
comment under the heading of task
oriented metrics we've been very focused
so far on comparisons with reference
texts and other Notions of intrinsic
quality but we should reflect on the
fact that by and large when we do
generation we're trying to achieve some
goal of communication or to help an
agent take some action right the
classical off-the-shelf reference based
metrics will capture aspects of the task
only to the extent that the human
annotations did so if your reference
texts aren't sensitive to what the goal
of generation was then that won't be
reflected in your evaluation
you can imagine model based metrics that
are tuned to specific tasks and
therefore task oriented in their nature
but that's actually currently a very
rare model
I think it's fruitful though to think
about what the goal of the text was and
consider whether your evaluation could
be based in that goal this would be a
new mode of thinking
you would ask yourself can an agent that
received the generated text use it to
solve the task and then your metric
would be task success
or was a specific piece of information
reliably communicated again we could
just ask directly whether the agent
receiving the message reliably extracted
the information we care about or did the
message lead the person to take a
desirable action which would be a more
indirect measure of communicative
success and that could be the
fundamental thing that we use for our
metric for Generation that will capture
some aspects and leave out some others
for example fluency but I think overall
you can imagine that this is much more
tightly aligned with the goals that we
actually have for our generation systems